thank you
come on little laptop
[Music]
why don't you start it's okay I mean I
don't think I have anything going on in
the margin of your life
what's up
okay thanks for thanks for coming to the
Taco thanks for the the organizers for
inviting me
um I want to talk today about something
uh hopefully maybe a little simple
um but it's some work that I did with my
PhD student process Nicola pakis who's
now a postdoc at uh Yelp
and uh so uh you know I thought I'm
going to a machine learning conference I
should talk about neural networks
um but I don't really know anything
about neural networks so this is the
neural network I'm thinking about
um uh so there's this thing people study
uh there was a poster lovely poster
yesterday
um on uh understanding functional
network connectivity which is trying to
understand uh relationships between
different regions of the brain uh
through sensing
and uh we often people often use uh fmri
to do this but uh fmri measures the
hemodynamic response uh in the in the
brain and it's kind of slow uh and it's
also expensive uh and Loud if you've
ever who here has had an MRI
yeah it's like being in the worst dance
club ever
um so then uh EEG people like to use EEG
but the number of EEG sensors in in the
typical uh the setup like toddler's
showing uh can be not so large but
people are proposing Now using high
density EEG
so this is the kind of problem uh that's
sort of motivating it I'm not actually
going to address this problem actually
so um but I just had to put neural
networks in here so
what am I interested in really uh we
have these kind of multiple spatially
correlated or monthly multiple
measurements which are correlated
um and that the measurements are
indirect this we're not actually
measuring directly the uh the thing that
we're interested in we're measuring uh
some it's kind of a remote sensing style
problem the remote sensing for those who
are in the younger set was a thing that
people were talking about you know a
long time ago
uh so uh we're interested in first in in
the uh it's also in the correlation
structure like we know maybe for the
first order I don't want to know
necessarily the weights between uh the
regions but you'd like to just know
whether edges are there in in in this
director so we want to look at a simple
model of structure learning from from
corrupted data
all right so
that's the setting um and I just want to
you know put a little fine point on it
this kind of problem appears all over
the place so uh you know I'm a
electrical engineer by training I think
about devices and that they are built
objects that measure things and the data
that we measure that's in your your uh
data set is actually uh measured with a
noisy sensor
um you could also think about
communication constraints and
quantization error or people like
interesting this is robustness we want
to think about adversarial attacks and
I've worked a little bit in the past on
differential privacy so uh there's uh um
and I still work a little bit on
differential privacy so in the
differential privacy as we know from
from yesterday noise is deliberately
introduced into the system so they're
actually I don't even have to make the
case for it the noise is there you added
it so
right so in this talk I want to talk
about uh uh this problem the way we're
thinking about this problem or problems
like this and the framework of Learning
Tree structured graphical models
uh in particular we're looking at a
hidden model problem so like uh you know
noisy version of the problem and try to
understand what can go wrong and then
introduce a quantity that we are calling
the information threshold which sort of
generalizes a an object that people
study when they study tree structured
graphical models
all right so
so what is graphical model selection for
those who don't know
um you have a joint Distribution on P
variables you can tell I'm I'm uh if
anybody's looking at Twitter yesterday
I'm displaying my affiliate affiliations
by saying it's p is the number of
parameters but
the the number of variables in the
distribution the p-dimensional
distribution as an unknown joint
distribution and we're trying to
estimate this distribution and
information
yeah yeah I know I know I'm I'm been
poisoned by the statisticians um so the
distribution uh has a factorization
structure which is given by a graph and
that's why we call them graphical models
and uh um we observe n samples from this
distribution so n n p dimensional
vectors and we'd like to estimate the
graph that's the goal
um
and uh you know in this case uh we're
asking I'm asking for something even
simpler I just want to know the graph I
don't want to know the actual
conditional distributions necessarily
all right so I was thinking about like
what was the oldest paper I could find
on on this topic and there's this paper
by Lewis uh from 1959 uh on
approximating probability distributions
to uh reduced storage requirements a
very few near and dear thing to to
information theorists and just appeared
in information and control and uh you
know the idea was to approximate some
complicated joint distribution he's like
oh no we have uh you know uh n Bits n
Bits is way too many or P bits I guess
PBS is very large we need to we can't
store distributions on p-bits to the P
things uh could it be histogram so let's
try and approximate it by by looking at
um lower order component distributions
which are just uh lower order marginals
um he wants to conserve storage space
and uh but is interested in those which
are particularly important in
characterizing the high order
distribution and of course we'd like it
that the approximation method that you
use actually do this so he proposed a
method actually based on uh KL
Divergence although it was a 1959 so
they hadn't started calling it KL
Divergence then it was uh
just uh uh he called it a maximizing
entropy
method but it wasn't like Max entropy
necessarily but anyway he was looking uh
to do this in KL
um the problem in general is very hard
um that is the sample complexity could
be exponential with respect to the
degree of the underlying graph and the
computational complexity can be and be
hard and so I don't like hard problems I
like easy problems so I'm going to stick
with the tree I'm going to assume that
it's a tree like the simplest graph I
can think of even forests are harder
than trees so let's stick with the tree
um uh so the distribution of X is
non-degenerate and factorizes according
to a tree and this tree is connected so
it's a tree not a forest and we're going
to assume that the
Mutual information between uh um
um is positive for all the original
pairwise variables
um I'd like to note that trees are still
useful I mean it's not I'm not doing
this just because uh you know I'm lazy
it's because trees are actually still
also interesting to try and approximate
also I can say something so it's good so
a classical algorithm for estimating
Tricia
I think that they're the same
that's why that's why I just had to put
that as a joke about neural networks at
the start of the talk soon
forget about it
um
called me out okay uh classical
algorithm for this is uh due to Child
new which was published in the it
transactions in 1968 so happy 55th
birthday to this paper
um we should have a cake later
um and it's very straightforward you
compute the empirical Distribution on
all pairwise repair variables on every
potential Edge and then you plug that in
to compute a plug-in estimate of the
mutual information between every pair of
variables and then outweigh the maximum
weight spanning tree and this is like a
pretty natural thing that you would
think about doing and in fact it's a it
turns out uh to be a pretty good idea
so cheers to them uh you know having
having brought us this lovely algorithm
uh so it's a pretty good idea overall I
would say ciao Liu
um it is in fact the ml estimate
estimate of the factorization structure
so this is uh you know we like maximum
likelihood it's a consistent uh
estimator
um uh in this uh lovely work from like
12 years ago
um would show that uh uh do some error
exponent analysis for those who are
really hardcore information theorists uh
as we all know
these are hardcore information theorists
um extension uh and you can if you want
to do Forest because you're like uh
Anand you're too lazy you should do
forests uh it's already okay Vincent has
done it for us
um and uh so there's a um extensions to
Forest it's also a good idea there it
has a an optimal sample complexity for
this learning to make predictions
problems or if I want to predict one
subset of variables from another subset
of variables so this is more recent work
by bresler and karzan
which is actually the what sort of
inspired us to think about this kind of
problem
and uh it can also be used in other
algorithms so you can use it as a piece
like a child you might not be uh itself
the thing to do but you could use it as
part of a more sophisticated algorithm
so it's a nice paper from last year
which calls it CL plus plus child U plus
plus
um that can handle things like model
specification
but that last Point kind of raises an
issue that's not like the best thing to
do all the time it's not always the best
thing to do so you need other ideas uh
there are other ideas out there for
estimating this tree interaction
screening or The Spar Citron are also
very good ways of estimating sparse uh
graphical models
um and if you're uh uh not quite in the
in the in the the plane situation that I
mentioned before with this
pre-structured model like if you have
noise
um or if you have outliers or if you're
actually not sampling from a
distribution but close by to a tree
distribution or somebody has corrupted
some of your samples adversarially or if
you have a different type of uh model
specification your then close close to a
tree but again in a different sense in
all of these cases you need something
more fancy than childhood
um so uh but I I you know uh I like to
to take it old school so I'm gonna stick
with ciao Liu and I wanna know what can
we say about child in this in this
context of noise
so and the reason I I want to do this is
I want to emphasize uh sort of metapoint
which is that the modeling assumptions
that we make uh have some semantic uh
value and so that you we when we decide
to set up a model for our problem we
should think about what does it mean so
I might be trying to distinguish which
tree I have right
um and uh so noise a noisy model could
say like well it's a tree but has some
junk on it so let's like try and recover
the tree that's uh that's a
straightforward
um one one way of doing it on the other
hand if I think about adversarial
perturbation I could say that most of my
data actually comes from a tree but some
of it's been poisoned some of the
samples actually come from broccoli and
so you want to get rid of the broccoli
um and then you want to then find you
know keep the tree keep the tree get rid
of the broccoli
um
but you could say also close to a tree
could be like the real data is actually
broccoli which looks like a tree
um so what is the closest tree that
looks like broccoli and I'd argue it's
the top top left one
um but uh so that's a different again
these are all kind of different ways of
of actually trying to say what it is
that you're how's what's the
relationship between the real world and
the measurements that you're making and
then of course you could have sort of a
robust statistics or uh or think about
rejecting outliers is uh most of my data
comes from this tree from the tree but
actually some of it comes from something
completely different I don't even know
what it is that's the Huber style robust
statistics model uh a percentage of it
comes from some other distribution like
slots and then we want to again get rid
of the the slots
um
so slots are not pretending to be trees
whereas the broccoli is kind of
pretending to be a treat so these are
kind of also different different
assumptions that you're making
so we don't often get to measure X
directly and so we're going to consider
a hidden structure uh problem
um so instead of the X's we're going to
measure y's y's our corrupted versions
of the X's
um and but the hidden model is still a
tree so we're going to assume that the
underlying reality is that things are
related to uh by a tree and what we want
to estimate uh what do we get to measure
the wise and then we want to estimate
the X's again
so that's a sort of straightforward so
the problem is then if on the face of it
maybe you don't know what the structure
is uh but then given n observations of
the Y how can you estimate T and in
particular the question we're interested
in is what is the impact of the the
channel or the relationship between X
and Y on the number of samples that you
need to estimate T from Y versus the
number of samples you'd need to estimate
T from X
at the moment we do uh we're trying to
characterize what is the impact or
interested in the we don't need it for
the estimator but we do need it to
understand what the bounds are going to
be like to pick the sample complex okay
but uh we're interested in the
um the question of uh you know what is
the impact of that channel on the on the
uh on the estimation so for example is
it worth spending another 100 to buy
better sensors that's higher SNR but
that would be a kind of question that
would be motivating this this any other
questions at this point
so um the work
the warranty data problem is a bit more
recent than the work on the um the sort
of classical child use so on so we did
some work on uh easing model trees which
are just binary with binary variables
um and IID binary noise so we pass every
bit every uh we have uh correlated Bits
And The Joint distribution factorizes
according to a tree we put that Vector
through a memoryless binary symmetric
Channel and that's what we get to
observing flip some of the bits
um people have looked at uh kind of
around the same time uh this group was
looking at uh Erasure channels and I
think Erasure channels are really
important to look at because in in
almost any real application uh you know
you talk to statisticians uh there's
always missing data and um we always
just assume we have a we've already
filled it in often so like missing data
is actually very interesting to to think
about I think
um if the noise isn't IID that is if the
noise uh both of the noises dependent
across uh variables and
um
and or has a different distribution at
each node then sometimes you can you can
show that in some examples the
um and I'll show one later that the
child the algorithm will fail that it's
the um
but if you know those differences you
can sometimes correct for it but there
are other algorithms which could work in
this in this setting where you have um
different different say bit slips on
every on every uh variable
um you can get a fancier algorithm if
you're interested in error exponents but
they kind of restricted to easing models
um so all these these results are
basically on underlying binary data and
then the X's are binary and you're
you're putting them through some binary
input Channel
um with the exception of this this uh uh
work which talks about a connection
between
um running Chao Liu uh on uh uh with
this continuous corruption model I think
they're motivated by problem in genetics
phylogenetics
okay so what we're interested in
actually is uh what happens when the X's
are we're not easing not binary so we
want to think about uh non do General
alphabets for for the x's and uh because
you know although as information
theorists I think it's an information
that there is I think that I should be
able to understand everything through
binary or gaussian examples there are in
fact other things to think about than
binary and gaussian examples but you
know
so and we want to understand what makes
a particular model in particular what
makes a particular noise uh uh model
easier or harder to make the problem
easier harder from an estimation
perspective
all right
so
um let's look at this uh uh hidden tree
uh
with discrete alphabet so I'll just set
up the model again we have P variables
with an unknown tree structure each XI
is going to be in some discrete alphabet
we're actually interested in both uh
both finite alphabet and uh countable
alphabets uh for a reason I'll give an
example in a minute
um if they're accountable we have to
make some assumption and an assumption
that we're going to have to make if any
of those anyone is familiar with the
this uh entropy estimation paper by
antos and countryanes if not you should
read it to read a nice paper
um you need to we need to uh be able to
estimate uh um
information quantities successfully so
we need to make some assumption about
how small the probabilities can get how
fast they get the probabilities can
Decay uh in the
um for the Distribution on x's and so is
it the Assumption we're going to have to
make
um so again we have this connected tree
and the observations are generated by
passing each x i through an independent
and in this case identical uh discrete
memoryless Channel and each y is going
to take probably also values in a
possibly countable alphabet so this is a
this I think now I've saved the model
three times so hopefully everybody's on
the same page
um so there are a lot of examples of
this uh obviously the one I said before
which is like a binary data and then you
flip some of the bits of the binary data
you can also think about categorical
variables corrupted by randomized
response
um this is uh the kind of situation
maybe a differential privacy perspective
uh that uh I'd be interested in
and then of course there's a another
example which I think is pretty
interesting which is that the um each
variable is poisson you're measuring uh
some poisson a number of arrivals and
you have a fit what you can measure
actually is only a thin version so
underlyingly there's like you know x i
photons coming in and you can only
measure y i at the photons uh and so I
think this is pretty interesting there
might be some connections like Cox
processes and stuff like that but uh
you could you could I would just like as
an example of like a thing you could try
to do like well Photon counting devices
don't are abnormal
hallucinatory uh
not register photons but I mean ever
um
I was trying to get a thin puffer fish
but I couldn't couldn't manage to make
that work
um so uh so what we want to do is let's
see what is child what can we do with
Charlie in fact is Charlie a good idea
in setting because Charlie was a good
idea actually in the binary case so
um so again this nice paper by Anton
cincontianes kind of analyzed the
plug-in estimators for for entropy these
estimators uh have some bias so there's
something you have to deal with uh in
the in the estimation
and uh
in the in the binary case you can
identify uh the source of error in the
child algorithm that is when does the
child legal algorithm fail it fails uh
precisely when you have a particular
kind of data processing inequality by
but I think of as a data processing
inequality violation
um
and so we can sort of generalize the
point the main point of the stock is you
can generalize this condition in the
noisy case as well so what can go wrong
so remember the childil algorithm is
compute the
um
compute the pairwise Distribution on
every Edge and then find plug-in
estimates of the mutual information and
then outweight the max output the
maximum weight spanning tree
so if we do that the problem is the
Markov random field if I think about the
the Distribution on the Y's the markup
random field is a complete graph so uh
if I wanted to think about you know
child U on on the face of it should not
work on on that in that setting because
uh in fact your underlying model if I
think about the Y's it's not a tree it's
a complete graph so
um
that is where that's why child you can
become an inconsistent estimator
um
but what you if you look at this very
simple example where you have kind of a
three variables where you have a weak
connection between X1 and X2 but a
strong correlation between X2 and X3
and then you have but you have different
noise levels on each one
uh then if you uh if you have a a
situation where the um
Mutual information between y1 and Y2 or
the y1 and Y3 is actually bigger than
the mutual information between Y2 and Y3
then you're going to end up constructing
a tree which doesn't doesn't get that
edge between Y2 and Y3
so
um and if you say and you're like okay
well that that when does that happen and
you chug through and your everything
boils down to the correlation
coefficient for the binary case so you
just get this condition on on the
relationship between these noise levels
that if there's some sort of threshold
on the correlation
um
uh will you know if you if if this if
this inequality is violated then child U
is bad uh or doesn't work
um so one approach is of course to just
like throw up your hands and give up but
you know these guys have been around for
55 years so I want to you know
see keep working with them
um but you can use it so you can use it
in a more complex algorithm and what we
observe actually in these binary
settings is that if if you do know
something about the noise model you can
do some pre-processing and this will
create a consistent uh make value
consistent again
so
um this is the sort of setting on the
the binary case and so the question is
um do we have similar setting uh in the
in the in the general case so
here's where I want to introduce this
information threshold
so when does child uh make mistakes so
basically we want to look at triples of
uh basically an edge uh in a in a path
uh you know a path with two endpoints
and an edge in the middle
and so what you can show is that the
child you estimator is not consistent if
you can find a path and the edge in the
middle such that the initial information
on the uh on that edge which should
exist in the graph is in fact uh smaller
than the beautiful information between
the two endpoints of the path so what
what will happen is those two will get
connected in this path this this this uh
this in this path W and W bar here will
not get connected but uh the endpoints
will get connected but they should they
should be connected
so uh that's that's what's going on so
if you rearrange this and you look at um
in the in the noises case you can just
sort of
say okay well what if I just look over
all paths and I try to find this minimum
uh or the the you know the the this Gap
uh here uh between the mutual
information on a link the weakest link
if you like and the and the endpoints
so if this if this Gap is strictly
positive in the noiseless case then then
in fact the error probability for the
child U algorithm decays exponentially
this is a result from planet Hall
and so we interpreted this as an
information threshold and asked in the
noisy case is it in fact the same
situation
um and here we always have uh that this
quantity is positive
um because of the data processing
inequality
um whereas uh in the noisy case uh it's
not necessarily is the case so if we
just replace X's with y's we can define
an information threshold here
um but this can be negative and in in
the case where this is negative it you
can show that child you will fail
um
but if you can look at the condition
whether it's positive or negative uh you
can generalize uh this this uh easing
model thing that I showed before with
this correlations you can generalize
this condition
um to to non-parametric models and so
then the question is well if this thing
is positive like how does this thing
relate to um the number of samples we're
going to need
and in particular if you can do some
pre-processing for example to make the
pre-processed version or post-process
version like post-process the data
um
you can force this thing to be positive
then you can show that that Charlie will
work on the on the post-process data
so here's a result
so if we uh fix a class of underlying
models for X
um and then we have some parameterized
family of noise variables then we can
find a constant such that the sample
complexity is like you know log P which
is what you want the Delta is the the
failure probability but it's one over
the information threshold squared
um
and so uh this holds for when this
information threshold is positive
um and and this this quantity is a
function of the distributions of the Y's
um we have a Converse which basically
says that unless you have uh if you look
at a class of models for which the
information threshold is bounded away
from zero uh then that bound uh if you
don't have enough one over that
information threshold squared number of
samples you will your estimator will not
work
since the Minimax lower bound so where
our contention is that this noisy
information threshold actually is
characterizing the sample complexity
it's a function of the of the of the
noise distribution
so what's good and bad about this so the
good part is that uh we can you know we
have a a quantity which says whether or
not both whether the estimation problem
is is uh this this is over all
estimators so this says that child U is
optimal
um for for this uh um for this class of
models with positive information
threshold
um the bad part is of course that the uh
the constant
um C is in the in the in the upper bound
is going to depend on the underlying
class of models so it you know
um it's not like independent of the
underlying model and the noise you know
so we need to you know
you can do some more investigating here
and uh of course in the the hidden thing
is like how do I actually calculate this
quantity and so I'm going to dodge the
bullet on that one and say I don't know
so
um in fact I will leave that for future
work so
um we can compute this quantity in some
simple cases uh like in the binary case
that I showed before
um
and uh one question we were we've been
asking ourselves had been asking
ourselves if we can understand the
relationship between
uh the noiseless informations that are
thrilled the noisy information threshold
maybe using some sdpi sort of stuff
um and how can you estimate this
threshold and um you know what are the
implications for privacy we haven't
really thought about that yet or yeah
yeah so I think that's all I have to
talk about so thank you very much
[Applause]
um
foreign
X
well they want to constrain myself to
child Lu I wanted to search for
the best tree distribution
uh and all I'm given are the Y's y given
X
you know if someone thought about
formulating that problem and what the
structure of that probably the best tree
approximation to the underlying
distribution so they're like joint
distribution so the the stuff that was
that I presented the references on like
model mismatch
um those are saying oh you're close you
know your distribution isn't true but
it's close to a tree which is a little
bit different than saying
um your distribution might be far from a
tree but you if you want to trade this
is the best tree you can get um that's a
different I don't I don't not sure
actually he's off the top of my head if
that's there but there you would
probably want to use a different
estimator
um
this is terribly stupid but this one
would work by Karma some of these other
guys yeah the robustry selection that
one of the references okay yeah so how
does that relate to this stuff okay so
it depends on the model I can't exactly
remember exactly which one I mean which
model it was but it's one of these other
noise models where you're actually
um well so some of them I can't remember
if that one is one of the ones where
it's the data the samples are poisonous
to some of the samples like a robust
statistics on samples come from another
distribution or it's one of the ones
where it's close you're sampling the
your distribution is close to a tree
within total variation distance and then
you want to I'm sorry I just no I also
don't I mean I don't remember which one
I don't remember myself
I'm not sure by the way to talk but uh I
have one question the you mentioned
result so but as a follow-up to that I
mean there was that try to work because
John Weissman so on on estimating uh
yeah yeah I think actually the the
potatoes I would say that
yes I would I would uh yeah so we uh I
think when we went through the argument
it turned out that
uh the interview estimation is not the
problem
so like I'm getting a better interview
estimator isn't a meaningfully change I
mean
uh but we shouldn't do that you know we
should use the better we should use the
best entropy estimator
but because we're basically not we're
not digging into the estimator
they're not explaining anything
particular about it
you mentioned adversaries yeah so if
each channel is an APC or something like
do you think some version of this would
work uh well I don't think if each
version is an ABC
customers
that is a very interesting question
so for those who are known ABC is an
arbitrarily varying Channel it is a a
channel that states that is controlled
by an adversary and the cost constraint
you're saying like for example in every
sample you could fit a flip at most a
fraction P so you could flip at most a
fraction Q of the bits
um uh in each sample and but that's done
in an adversarial way can you then say
something well I think you know the
thing is that uh and add some kind of
adversary like that might be able to
just delete a whole section of the graph
so then you actually I think it would
raise very different but also
interesting questions uh about what you
can see
um when somebody can Target the
erasers might be easier